[Musique]
- mon homme mahalo garde Jenny des
concitoyens noirs / roses de l'utérus hé
et j'ai une petite soeur puissante xuxa Je
ne t'oublierai jamais
[Applaudissements]
attends ça va savoir qui est le meilleur
rappeur du groupe pourquoi Shady était
définitivement  JT honnêtement il dit qu'il traîne
présente le meilleur
elle est vraiment comme elle est parfaite je veux
tout ce qu'elle fait tu sais d'accord pas
comme ça je pense que le meilleur rappeur est un
je suis dans Tecate B et qui est selon vous
la pire arme du rappeur milli source
[Musique]
Je pense que le pire des emballages de
cadeaux de Noël, c'est moi, mais dans le bon sens parce que
je le fais rapidement et efficacement, je ne perds pas
mon temps à le faire un par un, je les
jette tous dedans et puis je l'emballe tout de
suite  la trappe tu vois de quoi je
parle c'est le top c'est aussi moi
car je le fais très bien d'
accord tu peux faire un petit
message d'improvisation sur le coin je voudrais juste
souhaiter à tous de bonnes fêtes de
noel pour Hanukkah ou Kwanzaa
tout ce que vous voulez
joyeuses fêtes joyeuses fêtes  olidays Joyeuses
Fêtes Joyeuses Fêtes joyeuses fêtes
[Musique]
vous